in the last video you saw the building
boss of a single layer the single
convolutional layer in a confident now
let's go through a concrete example of a
deep convolutional neural network and
this will give you some practice with
the notation that we introduced to at
the end of the last video as well let's
say you have an image and you want to do
image classification or image
recognition we want to take as input an
image X and decide is this a cat or not
zero or one so it's a complication
problem so let's do the notional let's
build an example of a confident you
could use for this task for the sake of
this example I'm going to use a fairly
small image let's say this image is 39
by 39 by 3 this noise just make some of
the numbers work all a bit better and so
an itch it layer 0 would be equal to M W
height and width equal to 39 and the
number of channels and there a 0 is
equal to 3 let's say the first layer
uses a set of 3 by 3 filters to detect
features so f is equal to 3 already F 1
is equal to 3 because we're using 3 by 3
filters and let's say we're using a
Ghost Rider 1 and no padding so using a
same convolution and let's say you have
10 filters then the activations in this
next layer of the neural network will be
37 by 30 7 by 10 and this 10 comes from
the fact that you use 10 filters and 37
comes from this formula n + 2 P minus F
/ s plus 1 all right then I guess you
have a 39 + 0 - 3 / 1 + 1 that's equal
to the 37 so that's
like Oprah studies have invited in seven
it's a valid convolution and that's the
output size so in our notation you would
have an h1 equals n w1 equals 37 and MC
1 is equal to 10 so and C 1 is also
equal to the number of filters from the
first layer and so this becomes the
dimension of the activation at the first
layer let's say you now have another
convolutional layer and let's say this
time you use five by five filters so in
our notation F 2 and the Knicks there in
your network is equal to 5 and let's say
use a stride of two this time and maybe
you have no padding and say 20 filters
so then the output of this will be
another volume this time will be 17 by
17 by 20 notice that because you're now
using a stride of to the dimension has
shrunk much faster and 37 by 37 has gone
down in size by slightly more than a
factor of 2 to 17 by 17 and because
you're using 20 filters the number of
channels now is 20 so this activation a
2 would be that dimension and so an h2
equals n W 2 equal 17 and and C 2 equals
20 all right let's apply one last
convolutional layer so let's say that
you use a 5 by 5 filter again and again
is stride of 2 so if you do that I'll
skip the math but you end up with a 7 by
7 and let's say you use 40 filters nope
adding 40 filters you end up with 7 by 7
by 14 so now what you've done is
in your 39 by 39 by 3 input image and
computed you know 7 by 7 by 40 features
for this image and then finally what's
commonly done is if you take the 7 by 7
by 47 times 7 times 40 is actually 1 9 6
0 and so we continuous take this volume
and fatten it will unroll it into you
know just a hundred and tau into 1960
units right just as a fashion that out
into a vector and then feed this to a
logistic regression unit or a softmax
unit depend on whether you're trying to
recognize the cat no cat or trying to
recognize any one of K different objects
and then just have this give the final
output to find the predicted output for
the neural network and so just be clear
this last step is just taking all of
these numbers 100 or 1000 1960 numbers
and unrolling them into a very long
vector so then you just have one long
vector you can feed into softmax into
logistic regression in order to make a
prediction for the final output so this
would be a pretty you know typical
example of a confident but all of the
work in designing convolutional neural
net is selecting hyper parameters like
these society what's the filter size was
destroy what's the padding and how many
filters to use and both later this week
as well as next we will give some
suggestions and some guidelines for how
to make these choices but for now maybe
one thing to take away from this is that
as we go deeper in the neural network
typically you start off with larger
images 39 by 39 and then the height and
width will you know stay the same for a
while and gradually trend down as you go
deeper in the neural networks we've gone
from 39 to 37 to 17 to 40
since gone from 39 to 37 to 17 to 7
where as the number of channels which
generally increases come from 3 to 10 to
20 to 14 and you see this general trend
in a lot of other convolutional neural
networks as well but we'll give more
guidelines about how to design these
parameters in later videos but you've
now seen your first example of a
convolutional neural network more
confident for short so congratulations
from that and it turns out that in a
typical confident there are usually
three types of layers one is the
convolutional Meir and often we'll
denote that as a conflation in the
previous network it turns out that there
are two other common types of layers
that you haven't seen yet but we talked
about in the next cover video one is
called a pooling layer off now call this
pool and then the last is a fully
connected layer call FC and although
it's possible to design a pretty good
neural network using just convolutional
layers most neural network architectures
will also have a few pooling layers and
a few fully connected layers fortunately
pulling layers at Flickr mental layers
are a bit simpler than convolutional
layers to define so we'll do that
quickly in the next two videos and then
you have a sense of all of the most
common types of layers in a
convolutional neural network and you
really put together even more powerful
networks than the one we just saw so
congrats again on seeing your first full
convolutional neural network
we're also talk later in this week about
how to train these networks but first
let's talk briefly about pooling and
fully connected layers and then training
these will be using back propagation
which are already familiar with but in
the next video let's quickly go over how
to implement a pooling layer for your
confident